the u.s border patrol is overwhelmed
and yet we still haven't received an
adequate response from the biden
administration
that's why today i'm announcing that we
are deploying the national guard
on our own if this administration isn't
going to do anything
and we will arizona governor doug ducey
there
taking matters into his own hands by
declaring a state of emergency in four
counties
he's also deploying an additional 250
national guard troops to the border
his state is struggling to process a
record
number of influx of migrants and nearly
every day we see new images which
illustrate just how
serious the crisis is border officials
earlier this month stopped a commercial
trailer
packed with nearly 150 migrants trying
to cross
illegally into the united states none of
them was wearing a mask when they were
apprehended now remember we have to test
this
these people we have to treat these
people there's a whole lot that goes
into that
republican congressman chip roy of texas
joins me now
and he's pushing hard for a vote on
legislation that would reinstate
enforcement of president trump's covet
19 protocols
at our southern border as migrants over
crowd facilities
welcome to the program congressman first
of all tell me about this effort and why
it's so dire
harris glad to be on the show and first
let me just take a few seconds to thank
you for bringing up the absurdity of
what maxine waters did
and covering that and making the point
that she may have jeopardized the case
causing a judge to question whether or
not it would go down on appeal because
of what she said
in popping off and possibly tampering
the jury i really appreciate you
bringing that up
it's an absolute travesty but what what
else is it what else is a travesty
is what's happening at our southern
border uh cartels have operational
control of our border period anybody
who's following it knows that
tom alipas the state right across the
border from texas is run
by the dangerous cartels the reynosa
faction of the gulf cartel
and the cartel don the rest day of
lositas they are using human beings as
shields for profit
they're moving people into texas into
our communities into san antonio which i
represent
we've stopped vehicles with human beings
that are being sent to stash houses in
houston
to be used for profit into human
trafficking and sex trafficking the
district attorney in bernie a suburban
town of san antonio
they had a car load of nine individuals
two in a trunk and they were headed to a
stash house and one of the young boys in
there
had paid four thousand dollars to the
cartel the rest day
and to be sent to go pick grapes in
california but they didn't tell him
nope you're going to a stash house this
is happening the most powerful nation in
the world
we're allowing this to occur and
democrats refuse to do anything about it
kamala harris has been a quote on the
job for a month
literally she has done nothing she's not
gone to the border she's done nothing to
address this
so yes yesterday i filed a discharge
petition
of my friend yvette harrell's bill to
require title 42
the cdc's requirement and guidelines
that we protect against the influx
of pandemics into the united states that
we
resume enforcing that which the biden
administration has refused to do
so now we will force a vote on the floor
of the house if if we can get
up to six democrat colleagues to agree
that we should secure our border and
fight against the spread of the pandemic
and have you been talking with democrats
to see if you'll get that kind of
support
well first job is to get it down on the
floor we've now got signatures growing
and when all republicans sign it as they
should and will
uh we will then be working with our
democrat colleagues i've got great
friends like henry cuellar who's a
democrat down on the southern border
he understands how bad it is we've we've
introduced bipartisan legislation
i hope henry and some others will join
us in this effort uh but this is a
simple question
do you think we ought to employ all toy
tools at our disposal
to stop the flow coming across our
border and protect americans against
the dangerous pandemic when we're still
having lockdowns and still having
restrictions in place and we still have
mass guidelines and protocols here
why aren't we doing what we should do to
secure the border
so that just brings me to i i think it's
a pretty obvious question although i
haven't heard it asked
necessarily why would the biden
administration
wipe away title 42 and these protections
regarding covet
is there some sort of knowledge that the
pandemic has ended by the white house
that we don't know about
well i sure wish they would tell us so
that we can get all those small
businesses that are struggling still and
all of the
you know negative impacts on our economy
or schools that are still shut down i
hope they'll come out and tell us and i
wish they would just
stop putting dr fauci out there to
continue to confuse the american people
but
what's happening at our border they're
just doing it for political reasons this
is simple
uh they're allowing cartels to get
empowered mexico to become more
dangerous
texas and other states like arizona you
open this segment with
to have to deal with the crisis of
danger on ranches on our southern border
schools
well like i said human traffickers that
was an american citizen driving that car
being paid by the cartels by the way
it exists in your communities ladies and
gentlemen the cartels are operating in
your suburban communities and not just
in texas
and the democrat administration the body
administration they don't care
and they're ignoring what's happening at
the border with respect to covet
we know that there are covet infected
children in the facility in carrizo
springs how do i know that
i went there you know who hasn't gone
there kamala harris
because they only want to use this for
political purposes rather than doing
their job to secure the border
and this is the last point border patrol
you you talk to the border patrol union
regularly
brandon judd hector garza are great guys
down there they will tell you
title 42 is the tool they've got to be
able to stop the flow
at the border and be able to hold the
line and the democrats in the white
house
have already gotten rid of it for kids
and families but now they're rumbling
about getting rid of it for everybody
if they do that the bum rush at our
border will make the 171 000 in march
seem like a trivial number wow and and
i mean you know some of it falls on the
hands too
of the doctors and the nurses that will
have to help care for people
if and when they're found positive i
mean i've been reporting hundreds of
positives that have come out of that
testing
uh at the border and and so it becomes a
potentially dangerous situation that we
bear the brunt of
we're trying to save lives in addition
to trying to save lives
i mean it's a layering effect of them
coming across
and then coming across sick potentially
yes ma'am and can i just add that it's
also
part of the deterrent right you've got
the president of el salvador going on
tucker a few weeks back
and saying hey you're drawing people out
of my country you're decimating my
country
how about the seven-year-old girl that i
met with at the border i think you and i
may have talked about her before
who was all alone who was coming up
through mexico why
because the democrat administration is
encouraging the bible administration is
encouraging more flow
instead of using the tools we have at
our disposal to stop the flow at the
border
that's what this is about protecting
americans protecting immigrants
and not empowering cartels unfortunately
the vine administration doesn't want to
do that but i think we can force their
hand
with this discharge petition i would
encourage everybody ask your
you know uh congressman go get on this
discharge petition to force a vote on
the floor because democrats won't do it
on their own
all right we will bring you back
congressman chip roy to get a report an
update on all of that thank you very
very much for joining the program
thanks harris god bless you you too